hello everyone thanks for joining us for
CBN second annual virtual symposium that
advances in drug discovery and
development
I'm Matt Davenport an associate editor
with chemical and engineering news and
I'm delighted to introduce our next
speaker Emily Volquez associate
professor at Harvard University's
Department of Chemistry and chemical
biology before joining the faculty at
Harvard
Emily trained in a variety of fields
including synthetic organic chemistry
biochemistry and microbiology she
tackled projects that covered asymmetric
catalytic transformations and decipher
how photosynthetic bacteria produce
small molecules sunscreens her research
is now focused on problems she and her
groom find at the intersection of
chemistry and microbiology their goal is
to both improve our understanding
microbial biology and to learn how to
better harness these organisms ability
to produce chemicals if you'd like to
learn more about Emily's work check out
our feature on her in our towns of
12-issue
and of course stay tuned for a talk
right now entitled gut reactions
understanding and manipulating chemistry
from the human microbiota there will be
a Q&A session immediately prior that
presentation but you're welcome to
submit your questions at any time just
click the green Q&A button in the left
corner of your screen and to need
technical assistance through the
presentation please click on the support
button located the top or right in your
screen please note senior does not
endorse an accompanying product or
service that may be mentioned in his
presentation this talk will be archived
and available on demand ever I'm sorry
this top of the Captain available on
demand at the conference website for
three months after live broadcast until
December 16th of this year lastly if you
haven't already done so we'd love be
enjoying a Twitter conversation rated
days of them using the hashtag C and CIN
15 and that underlay the handle session
for the family hi everyone thank you for
the introduction that I'm really excited
to be able to participate in this
virtual symposium so if I start with an
outline for today's talk I'm going to
begin with a brief introduction say
human microbiota and how
study it then I'm gonna discuss my lapse
efforts to better understand
disease-associated chemistry from gut
microbes I'll then briefly comment on
the implications of the human microbiota
for therapeutics and then finally wrap
up with some concluding thoughts so
let's jump right in with an introduction
to the human microbiota so we live in a
microbial world microbes organisms like
bacteria archaea and bun die and have it
every conceivable place on this planet
and their chemistry their metabolic
activities influence numerous important
processes really on a global scale these
important organisms are what inspires
the research in my lab so the goal of
our research is really to improve our
understanding of the chemistry of
microorganisms and microbial communities
we're really inspired by the fascinating
biological rules of these organisms we
identify study and manipulate this
chemistry and in doing so we gain
knowledge that we hope will help us to
better understand the important
biological functions of microbes so very
broadly we're interested in questions
like these how can we most rapidly
uncover new microbial chemistry how can
we really zero in on the chemistry
that's important for the function of
microbial communities and then finally
you know can we develop methods will
allow us to really manipulate important
microbial functions and community
settings help us to understand their
contributions to biology better so I
think that some of the most fascinating
and important microbial communities we'd
like to study are our own so these are
the trillions of organisms that live in
and on us the so called human microbiota
so it turns out that we're actually more
microbial than human if you count up the
number of cells associated with a person
you'll find that microbial cells
outnumber our own cells about five to
one and microbes inhabit many locations
in and on the human body but the most
extensive community actually inhabits
the human gut and these are the
particular microorganisms that the talk
is going to focus on today so microbes
inhabit the entire length of the GI
tract a surface area that's about the
size of a tennis court they reach their
highest density in the colon which is
actually one of the densest microbial
habitats anywhere on the planet
so on average we each have several
hundred bacterial species in our gut and
collectively these organisms possess
about 150 times as many genes as the
human genome so we've actually known for
many decades that these organisms
influence human health like they have
many beneficial functions so they impact
important biological processes like the
digestion of food the development of the
immune system and provide protection
against pathogens there's also growing
evidence that changing the gut
microbiota can have negative
consequences for human health so altered
gut communities have been associated
with a growing number of human diseases
including IBD obesity and cancer it's
really important to recognize that we
really don't yet have a good
understanding of the mechanisms
underlying this biological influence so
we have understanding these organisms
are important but we don't necessarily
understand exactly how they're exerting
this influence so I think the question
on this slide is really emerged as a
major question in biology and medicine
something that's certainly important to
address in the context of therapeutics
so what are the reasons for this
knowledge gap well a big reason this
knowledge gap actually has to do with
the way we currently study the
microbiota so our information about gut
microbes largely comes from DNA
sequencing data so we isolate DNA from a
given body location something like the
human gut and then we sequence it now
there are very different there different
raters types in information you can get
from DNA sequencing data so one piece of
information that's quite straightforward
to get as information about fine lodging
eat this is because we have a good
marker for bacterial phylogeny in
sequencing data the 16s rRNA gene so
this allows us to get information about
who all the organisms at community are
and how they're related to one another
so whether they're present in a given
body site like the human gut we can also
look at whether there are correlations
between changes in community composition
which organisms are present and health
or disease dates so we've gotten a lot
of your sort of observed a lot of
interesting correlations doing this type
of experiment and say it's one of the
reasons why there's a lot of excitement
about the human microbiome right now the
really amazing correlations between
changes in communities and changes in
phenotype but this type of phylogenetic
information really doesn't tell us
anything about mechanism well why not
the reason is that microbial phylogeny
is very often not diagnostic of function
so a great example of this is actually
to consider some organisms that
hopefully were all somewhat familiar
with so our favorite lab strain of E
coli equal in k-12 and this strain of E
coli o157 h7 or e CAC this is the
pathogenic strain of E coli that's
associated with with food poisoning
there's no doubt that these organisms
are very different from a functional
perspective it's very different
potential consequences for your house
that you have one or the other of these
organisms in your gut
though this difference in function is
reflected in the whole genomes of the
organism so these two strains share only
about 46 percent of their genome but for
the perspective of by logic how the
organisms are related to one another
there are phylogenetic marker genes
they're almost identical so the final
drug marker sequence does associate with
these organisms differ by only a single
base pair so if you sequence a
microbiome and you look only at
phylogenetic information you can
understand who organisms are but that
information doesn't necessarily tell you
much about what organisms are actually
doing but we'd like to be able to do is
to look at DNA sequencing data and get
better information about biochemical
functions so look at all the genes
present in a given sample and get
information about what these organisms
are doing rather than just who they are
and I think this is a really critical
stuff we need to take if we want to
begin to come up with an hypothesis for
how these organisms may be influencing
biological processes so my group thinks
it's especially important to want to
understand the metabolic functions of
the gut microbiota so these organisms
ability to make and modify small
molecules there's multiple ways in which
the microbiota generates
small molecules that are unique from the
ones that that our cells produce and I
think this is a very amazing consequence
of having a microbiota were actually
exposed to a larger suite of molecules
than just the ones that our own cells
can be this occurs to a really
astonishing extent so about 10 percent
of the metabolites in human plasma are
derived from microbial metabolism and
interestingly metabolomics experiments
and in humans have found that in many
cases levels of microbial metabolites in
human plasma can be very highly
correlated with both health and disease
states so these are very interesting
observations that suggest that microbial
metabolites have the potential to be
interacting with our own cells in
potentially mediating biological
processes it turns out that we actually
know very little about the genetic or
biochemical basis for the production of
the vast majority of these got microbial
metabolites so to give you a sense of
you know how little we actually
understand this slide shows some data
from the human microbiome project so
these are stool samples genes that were
annotated from from stool samples for
148 healthy individuals so we're getting
a snapshot of the genes that are present
in each individuals that so a given
sample is shown on the x-axis and a the
y-axis are the percentage of different
genes in each individual that can be
annotated that can be given a potential
function so um we are actually able to
annotate only a small fraction of the
genes we find in these data sets and
even the functions that we do they can
potentially annotate are the functions
are quite broad and and most likely
inaccurate so this is definitely a
problem now the opposite issue for
metabolites and and metabolic functions
so on this slide I've shown some of the
metabolites that we know are made by
members of the gut microbiota and are
the ones that are have been shown to be
most likely to be mediating important
interactions with with host cells and we
actually understand very little about
the genetic basis for how these
molecules are made by the
and even more brightly we actually have
not characterized the vast majority of
molecules whose production is influenced
by my gut microbes so the reference I've
cited in the slide is a metabolomic
study that was done in mice and they
were able to identify science structures
only a small fraction of the plasma
metabolites whose presence was impacted
by by having a gut microbiota so we have
a long way to go in our understanding of
the chemistry of the microbiota
so my research group is seeking to
address this problem so we're using our
understanding of chemistry our ability
to think about microbial metabolism and
an enzyme mechanism to try to elucidate
the genetic basis for important gut
microbial metabolic activities so things
like metabolites they're linked to
disease so we are applying this general
approach to study many different types
of gut microbial metabolic activities
and so today I'd like to tell you about
just one of those projects I'm going to
tell you about how my group has
discovered the genetic basis for a
disease associated microbial metabolic
activity that produces this molecule
trimethylamine n-oxide and our efforts
to understand the contribution of this
activity to human biology so now I'll
talk a little bit about work from our
lab this project actually began in my
group with an unexpected observation and
this observation actually was some data
that came from a study run by Stan
Hazen's lab at the Cleveland Clinic and
so she was interested in performing an
untargeted metabolites experiment aimed
at understanding whether there were
metabolites in human plasma there were
predictors of future adverse cardiac
events so she ran an untargeted
metabolomic study and he found in this
first group of 75 patients a correlation
between adverse outcome and levels of
this metabolite trimethylamine n-oxide
in in plasma he went on to demonstrate
causation in a mouse model so you could
feed an atherosclerosis prone mouse
trimethylamine n-oxide and it would
develop more severe plaques will wrap
he then followed this study up with a
much larger group of patients following
them for a time period of three years
and found the same correlation between
plasma TMAO levels and risk for adverse
cardiac events so this is an intriguing
correlation but what does this have to
do with some microbiota well it turns
out that trimethylamine n-oxide is
ultimately the product of microbial
metabolism so it's derived from a gut
microbial metabolites trimethylamine
trimethylamine is a volatile molecule
it's it's the molecule responsible for
the smell of rotting fish and in our
bodies trimethylamine is exclusively a
microbial metabolites so our own cells
don't produce this molecule TMA is
produced by the activity of gut microbes
and one of the major sources of
trimethylamine in the gut is actually
the fermentation of the essential
nutrient choline so gut microbes are
going to process choline anaerobically
they perform a carbon nitrogen bond
cleavage reaction to generate
trimethylamine and trimethylamine is
further oxidized in the human liver by
an enzyme called flavin model oxygen h3
to give trimethylamine n-oxide so this
is an interspecies metabolic pathway it
has a gut microbial human component and
it turns out that both trimethylamine
and trimethylamine n-oxide
are connected to human disease so
increased plasma TMAO is associated with
heart disease as I mentioned it's also
associated with a growing list of other
diseases now the other ones have like
trimethylamine it has been involved it's
been appreciated for years but it's
involved in a different type of disorder
and inherited metabolic disorder called
trimethylamine urea so patients with
this disorder have mutations in the gene
encoding FM O 3 this leaves them with an
enzyme that's unable to convert all of
the trimethylamine their gut microbes
make two trimethylamine n-oxide so I end
up excreting trimethylamine they have a
very characteristic odor so one thing
that's fascinating about trying to
methylene urea is that this is I think a
rare example of a disease where a
microbial metabolites have got microbial
metabolites plays a very well-defined
role it's also very interesting how
these patients manage their disease
there's currently no drugs to treat
trimethylaminuria what patients do is
regularly take antibiotics to tamp down
their their gut flora of
really carefully modulate their diets so
presumably they're managing their
disease by actually manipulating their
own gut microbiomes okay so because of
both of these disease connections my
group became interested in you know
which organisms in the human gut were
actually responsible for fermenting
choline to generate trimethylamine and
we kind of quickly realized that nothing
was known about this
there was nothing known about the
genetic or biochemical basis for choline
fermentation and this is a problem
because you couldn't actually look at
microbiome sequencing data and make any
predictions about whether a given
persons that microbiome had the
potential to do this this chemistry or
not so um we were faced with food with a
challenge right so given a disease
associated function it was linked with
this complex that community knew how
white might potentially identify the
enzymes that were giving rise to this
process how might we connect this
metabolic activity back to microbial
gene so we could do this that we would
have a way of looking for this activity
in sequencing data and and even got my
probl comm genomes so we decided to take
an approach to solve this problem it's
called genome I so we decided to try to
use bioinformatics to rationally search
for potential choline utilization genes
in sequence 2 factorial genome sequence
genomes of organisms that could carry
out this metabolic activity now we're in
order to do this type of genome mining
experiment you need to have a very good
biochemical hypothesis that guides your
search and so we generated our
hypothesis by really thinking about the
chemistry of cooling fermentation so it
had been known for many years that
cooling fermentation involves an initial
carbon nitrogen bond cleaning event that
generates two products trimethylamine
and acid al dye so the acid aldehyde it
turns out is what the organisms actually
you're using as a source of carbon and
ultimately as a source of energy try not
to lean is simply weight released as a
waste product so we thought about the
chemical logic being used here the
carbonate into cleavage reaction
generation of an aldehyde product and we
recognized a striking similarity to a
different bacterial metabolic
at the moment realization so this
pathway also uses an initial carbon
nitrogen bond cleavage reaction this
reaction provides ammonia and acid
aldehyde and this is carried out by a
well-studied enzyme ethanolamine ammonia
is which is an adenosylcobalamin
dependent enzyme so this enzyme uses
radical chemistry it makes sense that
this enzyme should use radical chemistry
right so this is a very difficult
elimination reaction of a hetero atom
the c1 proton of ethanolamine is not
acidic you can't use as a base chemistry
to do this reaction I'm so nature's
involves the ability to use a radical
and so you know we we thought about the
potential parallel logic between these
two pathways and we wondered if the
similarities might extend to the actual
enzymes that were involved in in these
pathways so specifically we wondered if
the enzymatic machinery involved in
processing that he intermediate acid
aldehyde might be shared between these
two processes so this hypothesis and
illuminated a strategy for finding the
Coulomb utilization genes we decided to
look for homologues of the genes
involved in ethanolamine metabolism in
the genome of choline utilizing organism
this strategy was was successful so we
were able to identify a choline
utilization or gene cluster in this
organism diesel for Vibrio t sulfuric
hands this is a sulfate-reducing
bacteria that was actually isolated from
the gut of the sheep so in terms of what
what this cluster encodes we did find as
we have hypothesized homologues of the
genes encoding the acetaldehyde
modifying enzymes we also see the genes
shown in black there in the gene cluster
the structural components of something
called a protein micro compartment this
is a protein based organelle that
certain bacteria used to encapsulate
metabolic pathways and there's a similar
compartment used in ethanolamine
metabolism so it was not too surprising
to find it in this pathway as well and
what really was a surprised was that we
didn't see a homolog of the CNN bond
cleaving enzyme from Holmby metabolism
we didn't see him a lot about small
monied ammonia lights
said what we saw was a different type of
radical enzyme system a system called
glacial radical enzyme
names that enzyme choline trimethylamine
lays and we hypothesized that again due
to the potential parallels in logic
between the two pathways that this
radical based enzyme might be the enzyme
that was responsible for him burning
cooling to trimethylamine and SLE by so
we were able to use a couple of
different strategies to connect this
gene cluster to choline utilization so
we hadn't fast identified the first
pathway for choline fermentation in
bacteria so again this discovery that
the cooling cleaving enzyme was
potentially a radical enzyme was pretty
exciting from a couple of perspectives
so by survival enzymes are large protein
family found in anaerobic microorganisms
these enzymes use protein based radicals
and catalysis so the active form of the
enzyme is actually a rat hole that's
situated on a glycine and the enzyme
active site and this radical species is
very stable in the absence of oxygen the
radical has to be generated by the
action of a separate activating protein
member of the radical Sam enzyme family
so all fly Sirocco enzymes are precise
to share certain mechanistic features so
in all the enzymes characterized to date
not only is there conserved glycine
there's also a conserved essential
cysteine residue in the enzyme active
site it's been proposed that it's
actually this residue that mediates the
reaction with substrate so it's not that
the first step in catalysis is actually
information with bio radical that bio
Runkle interacts with substrate through
a CH abstraction that generates a
substrate base radical which can react
or rearrange in various ways depending
on the ends I'm giving you a product
base radical that product base radical
can then react with that cysteine to
regenerate the file radical and provide
product so the protein-based radicals in
these enzymes
actually used catalytically so blacks
back ball enzymes um
word no when we started our work to
catalyze a pretty wide range of
different transformations that are all
important for primary metabolism in
anaerobes so they promote essential
processes of like ribonucleotide
production they play important roles in
glucose metabolism they also promote
some more esoteric activities this
enzyme is involved in the anaerobic
metabolism of tommylee so the human gut
is a largely anaerobic environment so
perhaps it's not too surprising that
less radical enzymes turn out to be one
of the most abundant and enriched
protein families in the human gut
microbiota relative to other microbial
habitats so you think that they're you
know potentially really important family
to want to understand so again we had
found this this potential : cleaving
enzyme and we thought it was a
potentially a new member of this enzyme
family and if that was true it was kind
of exciting for the respective chemistry
because that enzyme was fertilizing
their carbon made to do bond cleavage
which was not a type of activity that
had been observed previously for these
anxiety so we were able to test the
hypothesis that this enzyme cut C or
choline tml ice was an enzyme basically
using in vitro biochemical
characterization so we were able to
hetero Ellis Lee expressed purify and
examining activity of both the
activating protein cut deep oohs and the
Glacial rattle enzyme cut C so this
slide just summarizes how big these
enzymes are working based on a bunch of
chemistry so we think that this
activating protein cut D is responsible
for generating the glycine centroid
radical see it uses a reduced
four iron four sulfur cluster to
homolytically cleave Sam Mazzola finding
generating refining and five prime deoxy
that is so radical intermediate
background will intermediate then
abstract hydrogen atom from the active
site glazyev cuts
generating active enzyme and once this
enzyme properly activated that it can
perform CN bond cleavage of choline so
this is what we observed when we because
to the enzymes in vitro we've been able
to to completely but constitute this
process process we detect chemical mean
formation and assays only in the
presence of all the assay components and
under strictly anaerobic conditions we
also screened a number of other
potential substrates including other
trimethylammonium between the
metabolites things like carnitine and
betadine
we also looked at other ethyl amine
derivatives and so far we've seen no
reactivity towards honey but Coleen's
enzyme appears to be quite specific so
more recently our efforts to further
understand the mechanisms enzyme have
focused largely on trying to understand
what features of it actually
differentiated from other glycerol
enzymes we've gained a lot of this
information from from some structural
biology that we've done in collaboration
with Kathy Brendan's lab at MIT so
recently we were able in collaboration
solved the crystal structure of this
enzyme so can't see the tetra mer in
this structure
it displays the common pool that's
characteristic of the glycerol enzyme
family and we were actually able to
solve a bunch of crystal structures this
enzyme the one I'm going to show you
today has choline bound in the active
site buried here in the middle of
protein and it's a 1.9 angstrom
resolution structure so come resume it's
that active site you can see how choline
is binding in in the active site so you
can see choline here and you can also
see a single water molecule that's found
in the active site so we can take a look
at this structure and you get some
information about various aspects of the
reaction so we can get some information
about how the reaction is likely being
initiated so again here's pulling here
is the glycine a site of the glial
radical if you can prepare where this
glycine is to where choline is bound in
the active site you see that it's
actually quite distant
in between perfectly situated is this
cysteine residue and so this is
consistent with my hypothesis that's
actually bile radical that's mediating
chemistry with substrate I also notice
that there is very short hydrogen
bonding interaction between a c1 alcohol
choline and this glutamate residue
I'm not consistent with this illuminate
being the general base that's important
for catalysis plays a role in forming
acid aldehyde so we've confirmed the
importance of all these residues using
site-directed mutagenesis all these
Newton's cuz that's no catalytic
activity and I'll just note that a
similar set of residues is observed
another Glaser radical enzyme that does
elimination chemistry glycerol
dehydratase or gdh another thing I'll
notice is the dihedral angle we see
about the c1 c2 substituents and cooling
this situates the pro-x hydrogen atom
which is the one we'd expect to be
removed from c1 based on this structure
almost perfectly intact carry cleaner to
the departing trimethylammonium group
potentially suggesting that this is the
direct elimination reaction so we are
also really interested in understanding
how the proteins apple might be
interacting with the trimethylammonium
group of choline so we can take a look
at some of the residues that might be
involved in those interactions so we
have an aspartate residue here that is
almost surely participating in
electrostatic interaction with the
positively charged
trimethylammonium we also see evidence
for the involvement of multiple kind of
hydrogen bonding like interactions
between the lone pairs of hetero atom
containing side chains protein including
this aspartate and a couple tyrosines
also the lone pairs the water molecule
here these are hydrogen bonding like
interactions between those lone pairs
and the CH bonds of the
trimethylammonium
methyl group so these types of
interactions are observed in other
enzymes that make
bind or or consumed tri methyl lysine
residues and so they're not new but this
is to our knowledge
the largest collection of them that's
been seen in any enzyme so they today
there's a lot of these interactions in
this structure and so we think
potentially they may be important for
helping to mediate the CN bond cleavage
reaction so we're in the process of
using mutagenesis and then Zyme kinetics
to better understand the rules of these
residues in choline minding and
catalysis we know already that several
are very important for function okay so
our understanding the mechanism of this
reaction is still very much a work in
progress I wanted to share one potential
mechanism you can draw that would be
consistent with what we see in our
crystal structure so again we think that
the bile radical is is abstract in the
pro-ice hydrogen atoms we've seen one of
choline this will generate a substrate
based radical almost certainly you have
a direct elimination of trimethylamine
could proceed through intermediate
that's been deprotonated see one alcohol
once you release your methylamine
Foreman oxalic can is a little radical
and this could react with the file
dialogue cysteine to give you the file
radical back so we're in the process of
doing some computational work doing some
additional experiments to prove this
mechanism but so far this proposal is
consistent with all the assays we've
done so far with labelled substrates
okay so so we're we're doing quite a bit
of work to understand this enzyme and
what their details underlying how it
functions you know why is this important
why do we care about how this enzyme is
actually working well it turns out this
information on the combination of two
information about activity information
about structure allows us to really
understand the the sequence function
relationship of this enzyme and that in
turn gives us information that actually
helps us to differentiate this enzyme
from other members with less radical
enzyme family so there are lots of these
things in microbial genomes up in
sequencing data from the human gut we
really need to be able to differentiate
schooling thieving enzyme from other
members of the family if we want to
really be able to accurately identify
organisms that have this metabolic
activity so our understanding of the
structure has allowed us to do that we
know that all the residues that interact
with the trimethylammonium group are
very conserved among colon cleaning
glycerol enzymes but are actually unique
to that set of cherries are not found
other members of that family so we can
take this knowledge we can then go back
and do further bioinformatics so we can
mine genome sequences mine metagenomes
and for the first time really accurately
identify potential choline degrading
organisms so we have found that cuts a
gene and and the cut gene cluster are
widely distributed in the genomes of gut
bacteria and also in human gut
meta-genome so - we also were certain we
did this initial analysis to actually
get some of the strains we identified by
automatically in our lab and make sure
that the presence of the cutsy gene in
an organism's genome is actually
diagnostic of that organisms ability to
degrade choline so sure some of those
results with you so we've identified the
cut-scene cluster in over 400 bacterial
genomes this data is little over to date
we now have seen this cluster and you
know more like about 600 bacterial
genomes the majority bees organ the
organisms are human derived we see this
the cluster in both pathogens as well as
commensal gut microbes and there's also
a large tumor environmental organisms
and organisms that live in close
association with plants and animals so
we were able to detect cutsie genes in
almost every stool mat as you know from
the human microbiome project and these
are gut microbes from from healthy
people so this this gene is present in
people so that so that's very exciting
and these genes are always associated
with with clusters and really display a
very high degree of sequence similarity
despite as you'll see there the fact
that they're distributed over a wide
range of bacterial diversity so this
sort of shows you
the distribution in different
environments what about the types of
organisms that have this cluster so we
were initially kind of surprised to find
that you know this fact way is not
limited to a small subset of microbial
diversity it's not limited to a single
phylogenetic group organisms we find
this pathway in organisms from multiple
bacterial phyla so we see it notably in
some entities which are one of the two
major phyla that dominate the human gut
microbiota and we also see it in a lot
of Proteobacteria now this wide
distribution is suggested potentially
that this pathway has been passed around
these organisms and acquired through
horizontal gene transfer we did a
phylogenetic analysis of this protein
sequence and analysis supports the
hypothesis that this has been acquired
de corazon gene transfer the other piece
of evidence that supports that
hypothesis is the uneven distribution of
the cluster across individual groups of
bacteria so on this slide we're looking
at the different genre of cut clustered
containing organisms that are found in
the human gut and the percentage of the
total genomes of that genre that
actually had to cut Buster and so you
see a really wide range in terms of
carriage of the cluster among these
different phylogenetic groups so it's
not easy to look at an organism that's
of a particular phylogenetic group and
then really make a prediction about
whether that organism is likely to have
the cluster or not this actually has
important implications so the
phylogenetic composition of the gut so
just knowing which organisms are present
in that community is not likely to be a
good predictor this metabolic activity
so I think this is likely to be true of
many other metabolic pathways as well
because of issues like horizontal gene
transfer this is important right if we
want to be studying particular metabolic
pathways particular functions in this
environment it's not enough to know
which microbes are present in a
community we have to have methods of
directly detecting
our function of interest
so we were in the process of developing
such tools the you know things like
selective pcr primers and things that
will allow us to detect the abundance of
the the cut jeanss transcripts and
proteins
we'd like to detect these these these
genes trans different proteins in both
model hosts so we're doing that in
collaboration with the University of
Wisconsin we also like to be able to
look for the markers of this function in
samples from human patients and
ultimately and try to see there really
is a correlation between the abundance
of this specific bacterial metabolic
pathway and the levels of metabolites
like TMAO and GMA in human plasma
okay so we're also working to identify
small molecules that can inhibit cooling
and metabolism inhibit TM a production
and and and hopefully in that way
manipulate levels of TM ASD mao in model
hosts so the envision using such
molecules as tool compounds primarily to
help us decipher the role of this
metabolic activity in microbiota really
see if this particular pathway has a
connection to disease one could
potentially imagine using this strategy
therapeutically particularly for people
who have that disorder trimethylaminuria
um one other thing I'll just mention is
that our studies of this enzyme
including traumatic elias have also led
us to become interested more broadly and
other gut microbial glycin rival enzymes
so we we knew from the enzymes that have
been characterized we began our work but
this enzyme family really plays really
critical roles in a wide variety of
primary metabolic pathways and anaerobes
we also knew these enzymes were
widespread in the gut microbiota and so
we're currently working to better
understand which enzymes are actually
present in in-depth communities and
predict what they might be doing now in
order to do this well we really needed a
way of being able to look to the global
look at the family so not just
everything that was known or had been
characterized but but all the predictive
members of
this family so we've done not using a
strategy called network analysis so what
you're looking at on this slide is a
sequence similarity Network it describes
the relationship between roughly 27,000
different members of this protein
families the way this network is we're
gonna is that a single node like this
one here represents a set of sequences
but all have 95% sequence identity and
two nodes will be connected by an edge
if they have a pairwise alignment score
of better than e to the minus 300 so
this is a way you know when you can
start to network like this you
constructed in such a way that you group
characterized enzymes enzymes that have
known functions together in isil
functional clades and so this is
actually the clade that contains the
coaming trimethylamine lyases and so the
way we can start with this network the
other biochemically characterized
enzymes cleaned very pretty nicely as
well and everything that's shown here in
gray is actually a clade we can't assign
a function to so there are actually many
plates of unknown function missing the
network then shows you the members the
family that are found in human
microbiome project records genomes you
can see that both the the known and
unknown enclaves are found in these
organisms so we're currently working on
identifying the functions of several of
these uncharacterized clades and we're
using data from human patients to really
guide that analysis or figuring out what
unknowns are really abundant in people
who are healthy or diseased really focus
our efforts on to your orphanage those
enzymes we think that these less radical
enzymes are going to be really useful
markers for many bacterial functions
because of their critical roles in
primary metabolism potentially give us
readouts of both beneficial as well as
harmful pathways and again in the case
of disease associated functions things
like trimethylamine formation there's
the possibility these enzymes could be
relevant for therapeutics ok so this
brings us then to the discussion of the
microbiota and therapeutics and
you can imagine the information we're
really rapidly learning about the human
microbiota really over the past decade
especially has rapidly opened up new
questions and opportunities related to
therapeutics so I think that one of the
major implications of understanding the
microbiota has been really gaining a new
appreciation for the potential effects
that therapeutics people may be taking
might be having on our microbes so this
is of course particularly worrisome when
it comes to antibiotic use we appreciate
that antibody used in flips collateral
damage to the microbiota and Marty
Blaser and others have proposed that the
rise in certain autoimmune diseases that
we've seen over the second half of the
last century may actually be due to
overuse of antibiotics and they may be
causing the disappearance of
microorganisms that may be interacting
with the immune system and beneficial
ways so along with the of course
critical issue of antibiotic resistance
you know I think that that worries like
this are one of the reasons people are
rethinking you know how and when we use
antibiotics in addition to being
affected by drugs we might take the
microbiota can also have an impact on
drug activity they can directly
metabolize drugs changing their
activities so this is a particular
example my lots been involved in study
this is an example of I've got my group
in activating reducing a functional
group on the cardiac drug digoxin
abolishing its its effectiveness in in
certain patients that microbes can also
in addition to directly in activating
drugs through their own metabolic
activities they can also produce
molecules things like Parekh resaw that
have to be metabolized using the same
enzymes that are involved in metabolism
of drugs we take and so things like the
levels of character so your gut microbes
are making can influence the
pharmacokinetics and efficacy of other
drugs and so this inter-individual
variation got microbial metabolism could
potentially explain some of the
different responses the different
individuals have set to taking drugs
so certainly understanding this aspect
of the microbiota has implications for
both drug development as well as
personalized medicine okay so another
interesting question of whether is
whether gut microbes and the metabolites
they may be making are an interesting
source of new therapeutics so can we
actually isolate molecules from gut
microbes that possess interesting
bioactivity
so so so we can one example molecule
that's been isolated from the gut
microbe I produce 4G list and and it has
immunomodulatory activity is this
molecule polysaccharide a we also of
course known about microbes have the
potential to make complex small
molecules and so we can look at the
genomes of gut bacteria we can look at
metagenomes and we can bind biosynthetic
gene clusters that appear to encode the
potential to make more complex
metabolites so so I think this is an
exciting area of research currently
because we've co-evolved with our
microbes as we evolved it's certainly
possible that molecules these organisms
may have really evolved to interact with
targets of host cells and so it's
entirely possible that we could find
interesting therapeutics by trying to
unfetter understand microbiota host
interactions and then finally a major
question that has emerged in the in in
this areas is the question of whether it
will be possible to treat or prevent
human disease by manipulating the
microbiota rather than manipulating our
own cells so of course one of the major
successes in this aspect of microbiota
research has been the use of fecal
transplantation to treat Clostridium
difficile infection so I'm showing here
a figure from this New England Journal
of Medicine paper that came out a few
years ago this compared fecal transplant
to the standard of care vancomycin and
people transplant to be superior to
antibiotic treatment and so I think
there's certainly the success of people
transplant is a demonstration that
changing gut microbes can provide
beneficial therapeutic outcomes at least
in the case of this particular
infectious disease
I think we've yet to see if this
strategies will be effective for other
diseases but what are some of the other
ways we have potentially deleting that
that microbiota so one strategy is to
introduce isolated bacterial strains and
so they've got community that have
beneficial properties of probiotics
these can potentially be engineered
perhaps that's an area of interest
another strategy instead of
administering live organisms would be to
simply manipulate the nutrients that got
microbes see in a way that promotes the
growth the beneficial organisms so
understanding the role of diet its
impact on microbiota and you know
essentially the idea of adding specific
ingredients that promote the growth of
certain microbes things like prebiotics
is one strategy that is interesting to
consider well what about this idea that
I mentioned earlier
so our gut microbes themselves an
interesting target for small molecule
therapeutics so what would really be
potential benefits of doing something
like this well you know one potential
advantage is the level of precision you
might be able to have if you think about
the ways we currently have of negating
the microbiota with small molecules were
really limited to very blunt tools so
things like broad-spectrum antibiotics
these are going to inflict damage on a
large chunk of gut microbes so when what
we're envisioning doing is trying to
potentially develop small molecules that
target specific metabolic activities I
think this is a really complementary
approach such inhibitors if we can
develop them could be really useful
tools for deciphering the rules this
metabolic pathways may be playing and
complex microbial communities there's
not a lot of ways currently of
manipulating activities in complex
microbial communities with any sort of
precision and again in the context of
certain diseases this could potentially
be a therapeutic strategy to consider
now certainly there are many challenges
associated with this approach many of
these challenges are similar to the
challenges associated in high biotics
most notably difficulty of access
intracellular targets the diversity of a
potential target certainly that's
something we see with the Colima
traumatising enzyme that it's
distributed across a wide range of
bacterial diversity so there's certainly
challenges that will have to be faced
and considering this this approach to
therapeutics so it is interesting to
note that this has been done
successfully so there's proof of concept
for this idea out there so this slide
shows work format ribbon bows group at
UNC Chapel Hill so if he was able to
actually use in vitro high-throughput
screening so with an actual isolated
enzyme assay to identify an inhibitor of
beta glucuronidase enzymes from bacteria
this is the molecule that he discovered
so this molecule was effective in
preventing this reaction so this is the
removal of lugar on ID from the cancer
drug are going to take in this reaction
the bacteria removed this sugar in the
gut she used the sugar as a source of
carbon this results in a reactivation of
her vanity can in the lumen and this is
responsible for a problematic side
effect of this this cancer drug what
Matt's lab found is that administration
of this molecule to mice actually
prevented this dose limiting side effect
so there there's pretty much concept for
this idea and I think that this is you
know a very exciting area for for a
research in the future okay and and of
course you know I think that that you
know developing small molecule tools to
probe this aspect of human biology is
potentially rain which which chemists
can make a really critical contribution
to our understanding of the microbiota
okay so some conclusions and takeaways
from from this talk so I think what you
know going back to my labs on research
and what we've accomplished is to go
from a disease linked metabolic activity
fermentation of choline to form time up
this activity was associated complex
microbial community you know we've been
able to go from that activity back to a
specific enzyme whose role within the
microbiome we're beginning to understand
and we cannot think about beginning to
target with with small molecules so our
understanding of chemistry not only
helped us to find this target it also
helped us to understand its distribution
within the microbiome and we think that
generally knows that the infrastructure
we've put in place this approach will
hopefully provide us and others with a
roadmap that could be used to study
other disease associated microbial
functions more generally I hope I really
conveyed that understanding of chemistry
and the ability to think about how
enzymes work and how much travel is on
works at a molecular level can really
play a key role in identifying um new
enzymes in the microbiota this work is
also certainly revealed some of the
challenges associated with targeting
pathways from gut microbes name of the
broad distribution of functions across
the range of organisms I hope I
convinced you that got microbial
metabolic activities and got microbial
metabolism is really potentially
exciting new new frontier for drug
discovery decks so with that I'll just
quickly thank the people who have done
this work so most of the work I talked
about today was the work of a single
very talented graduate students mirando
boudin she's been joined recently by by
two postdocs dr. ana martinez Ocampo who
did all the the microbiology and
bioinformatics with cuts eat and then
also Spencer who has done all of the
more recent network analysis and
bioinformatics with less radical enzymes
so we have a number of terrific
collaborators as well and I think all
the agencies in slide for financial
support alright so I guess it's over to
chew on it yeah thank you so much for
that fantastic talk um so got a lot of
great questions gets you so I'll so
that's what I'm sort of like oh yes I've
got a teaching question which is you
talk about at the end day there are a
number of diseases that can tend to be
treated with the strategy can you talk
about
some of the examples that you think are
maybe most interesting right now is that
our most interesting to potentially
treat well I know that there's a lot of
interest in examining IBD so Crohn's
disease and colitis and there's
definitely I think evidence for the
shifts in the microbiota that are
associated with those two diseases you
know really helping to drive the disease
phenotype it's still not clear whether
the disease is triggered primarily by a
change in the microbiota but certainly
once you have that dysbiosis phenotype
you promote a microbial community or
microbial communities established that's
pro-inflammatory and so I think that you
know the understanding we have of the
role the microbiome plays in IBD is you
know creating much excitement about the
possibility of being able to serve use
that knowledge um for for therapeutic
development so that's one example of a
disease thank you so much so as much as
right back to the association of TMAO
with cardiac disease and the question is
do you think it's the TMAO itself that's
the culprit or isn't just a marker of
needing trimethylamine and I guess how
do you different how can you
differentiate between those two states
that is a question everybody wonders
about when it comes to TMAO and heart
disease so the primary piece of evidence
for causation in TMAO actually directly
playing a role in in the progression of
atherosclerosis came from the original
2011 nature paper from Stan Hazen's lab
where he actually fed TMAO to mice to to
the fov knockout mice and and saw
enhanced accelerated plaque formation
so he could see that effect when fed
TMAO he could also see that effect when
he fed Cooley but what was interesting
was that the effect with choline was
dependent on the mice having an attacked
microbiota so if he first given us the
mice antibiotics to knock down their
their gut microbes feeding choline no
longer had a adverse effect so that was
really kind of further evidence that it
was really TMAO in that mouse model that
was you know having the direct impact on
flat formation now of course that's one
mouse model you know I think in humans
it gets more complicated and there are
definitely several aspects to that
correlation that did you know give one
cause in terms of you know thinking
about whether the the direct your sort
of causation a role for TMAO actually
makes sense so you know one thing to
consider is that of course one of the
best dietary sources of TMAO is marine
fish there's no epidemiological risk for
heart disease associated with eating
marine fish in fact is the opposite of
course it's complicated because when you
consume marine fish your concern me much
more than TMAO but yeah so there's there
certainly is a question in humans if it
is really more than just a correlation
or not you can imagine that if you have
a disease like cardiovascular disease
you change as a hoax the environment you
provide for your bat microbes changes
it's entirely possible that you your
body actually changing promotes the
growth of organisms with slightly
different metabolites since that could
be why we see changes in certain levels
but yeah so no one has yet to identify a
mechanism a target by which TMAO would
actually modulate a pathway that would
make sense in terms of heart disease
work from Stan Hazen's lab and others
has shown that when you artificially
manipulate the expression levels of FM
III you see changes in cholesterol
metabolism
it's not something that you would have
anybody would have thought would be the
case and so there certainly are some
hints that maybe there are there are
differences in cholesterol metabolism
when you have high levels of TMAO or
high levels of the enzyme that's
generating TMAO but it's it's still very
early days in our understanding of the
host side of that correlation thanks a
lot I know that there's actually a
couple great talks coming up at 3:00 so
we'll wrap up with a few more questions
here and so that so the one I have here
right now is could be increased TMAO RTM
a platinum levels populations at FM o3
absence are allowed to be polyworks
and I guess my my my understand that
question would be how do you
I guess identify that what you found is
in fact what's responsibilities the
question is it written down somewhere
question 12 question 12 increased TMA
could increase GMA plasma levels be
related to FM o3 absence so yes I mean
we would know that from from the
patients who have trimethylamine area so
those patients have FM o3 dysfunction
they have low activity they're not able
to convert all of the TMA that their
their microbes makes TMAO so they do
have increased TMA excretion in the
urine relative to TMAO and so there's
actually an interesting group of
patients to look at the question I often
get is are there any is any protection
sociated with having sort of low
activity FMO 3 I'm certain that there
are people studying trimethylaminuria
patients now to try to answer that
question
they are that mutation is not associated
with any adverse health risks apart from
sort of the psychological distress
associated with you know having odour
and so this was the social debilitation
that comes with that
that disease could they be protected
against heart disease potentially but we
don't know the answer to that question
yet great thanks again unfortunately
ahead of time but again thanks to Emily
for that fascinating presentation thanks
to all of you for cleaning enhance means
such great questions there are more
talks for the rest of the day starting
at the top of the hour I can find a full
program on the agenda page locally at
the upper right hand side of the screen
in the meantime please stop by the
virtual exhibit hedonic and / want to
check out our sponsors and exhibitors on
network with other attendees thanks
again for attending this is matt
davenport for chemical engineering news
enjoy the rest of suppose IAM